middle-earth shadow of mordor feature  series explores the powers of the Wraith  Talia's lethal range of skills are  greatly enhanced by the Wraith but it  will take more than just combat to bring  down sour owns more machine that soul  thori won't protect you from my play the  Wraith grants the Ranger with the  powerful ability to dominate and  terrorizes enemies domination allows  talion to pierce the minds of his  adversaries identifying their strengths  and fears by avoiding his enemy's  strengths and exploiting their fears  talion can make even the most savage of  warriors flee in terror my loyal dogs  will die before they let you touch me do  your worst the combination Wraith powers  in a dynamic living world of the Nemesis  system allows each player to craft a  unique experience on every playthrough  dominate terrorize and turn your enemies  against each other as you cause chaos  amongst our own ranks leave your mind